antes de comenzar me gustaría realizarle
es una sencilla pregunta quién cree o
considera que tiene muy bien planeado su
futuro
ustedes no levantaron la mano y quiero
decirles que está bien y esto normal
tener dudas en esta etapa de nuestra
vida pero también quiero decirles que
necesitamos cambiar hacia una actitud
diferente que nos lleva a caminos únicos
con una mentalidad innovadora
acerca de cómo nos desarrollamos los
jóvenes puede encontrar muchos de los
problemas a los que nos enfrentamos en
la adolescencia que es cuando tenemos
más inseguridades acerca del resto de
nuestra vida problemas como lo son las
decisiones que marcarán mi futuro lo
mejor para mí o surgen dudas
pero lo más importante es que al igual
que las dudas surgen nuevas
oportunidades
es una breve historia de fracaso que me
hizo cambiar la perspectiva de la vida
y amo la física hasta tiempo me llegó la
oportunidad de participar en un concurso
llamado olimpiada de física estaba muy
entusiasmada por entrar
y desde ese momento supe que habría un
nuevo reto para mí porque al llegar al
aula
compañeros eran hombres
sólo haremos tres mujeres incluyéndome
pasaron las semanas y quedamos sólo unos
cuantos chicos y yo como la única mujer
y el miedo mayor porque me estaba
creando paradigmas que hacen que me
sintiera con menos oportunidad y que yo
no pertenecía ahí
si en verdad esto no es para mí
porque soy la única mujer
esto me diste de la competencia y bueno
pero no es en la historia muy larga de
serte
de ser te y hasta la fecha reconozco
este como uno de los mayores
oportunidades de las que más me
arrepiento haber desaprovechado
experiencia no fue en vano pues me ayudó
mucho a reflexionar que tal vez existan
muchas y muchos
con esta inseguridad de desafiar a lo
desconocido
probablemente no la vuelva a tener y
quizás yo piense que yo si pueden y yo
no
y esto se debe a la cultura que tenemos
en la actualidad
donde es mal visto desafiar lo que ya
tiene un orden
yo respondí a mi propia pregunta yo
puedo claro que puedo y la mujer claro
que puede no me malentiendan yo no
quiero generar y excluir esto a solo un
género lo que yo quiero es mostrar los
beneficios del empoderamiento para todas
y todos
porque el empoderamiento nos puede abrir
miles de puertas y nos puede hacer
sentir capaces de cosas que ni
imaginábamos el empoderamiento tiene
mucho que ver con el conocerte a ti
mismo saber cuáles son tus mayores retos
y miedos al hacer algo puede que tu
mayor retos sean los comentarios de
otras personas un impedimento físico o
económico donde tú fijes tu mayor reto
lo más eficiente para llegar al
siguiente nivel es asumirlo aceptarlo
pero no detenerte por este obstáculo uno
de los mayores retos a los que nos
enfrentamos la gran mayoría son los
estereotipos
de comprender pues es algo que está tan
normal
y los roles impuestos pero mira
puede ser más detallista que una mujer
puede ser más ruda que un hombre
desde ejemplo es por lo que yo quiero
llegar es que nadie tiene su destino
predicho y tú
el creador de tu propia
si a alguien no le parece lo que estás
haciendo continuas
más apoyo encontrarás de las personas
correctas
en lo que sí es importante enfocarse es
en tus alternativas de cómo puedes
explorar el mundo somos jóvenes y por
esto mismo necesitamos explorar nuevos
caminos hacia futuros que incluso nunca
imaginamos es entonces donde cambiamos
nuestra pregunta de por qué si pueden y
yo no a una pregunta más que yo no tengo
libertad en ese ámbito si lo quieres lo
puedes hacer pero debes de tener en
cuenta que tu objetivo debe ser real y
que en verdad lo quieras
porque lo quiero porque creo que lo
quiero
aquí un punto muy importante saber si lo
quieres o crees que lo quieres busca
desde donde te surgió esa chispa y esa
duda que te hace creer eso en este punto
muchos jóvenes se detienen porque toda
su vida ha sido un objetivo que en
realidad nunca quisieron y sólo lo
hicieron por seguir a la multitud y los
comentarios de otras personas para que
tu objetivo se materialice necesitas
hacer algo que en realidad en azca y
quieras
retomando un poco el empoderamiento
también tiene mucho que ver con la
valentía y la de seguridad que tú tienes
en ti mismo y para esto necesitas
desarrollar todas tus capacidades y
habilidades
ten en cuenta que no tiene ni puede
tener té nadie
está en un entorno tan débil como lo es
en méxico donde todo es muy superficial
y arraigado con lo normalmente aceptado
estamos alrededor de una sociedad que
aún no conoce su máxima capacidad
ahí es donde entramos nosotros los
jóvenes no vamos a imponer pero vamos a
mostrar liderazgo expresando ideas hacia
soluciones a problemas que incluso ellos
ni siquiera han visto y para esto no
tenemos una herramienta fundamental el
cerebro el cerebro del ser humano tiene
la capacidad de desarrollar su
imaginación y creatividad a su beneficio
y esto nos va a ayudar a poder ver
diferentes perspectivas y ángulos hacia
problemáticas y proyectos que tenemos
es entonces donde surge la innovación y
la innovación como ustedes sabrán es
algo que necesitamos en esta social
aventurarte puede que no sea fácil o
algo que contemple es viable en este
futuro pero es porque así nos han
enseñado a seguir un patrón y un camino
ya he hecho pero tú puedes crear tu
propio camino
personalmente yo no me imaginaba estando
aquí en frente de todos ustedes
expresando tan abiertamente mis ideas y
se imaginan que sería de cada uno de
nosotros si no tomábamos una cierta
decisión las oportunidades no siempre
aparecen de manera tan fácil puede que
necesites buscarlas o puede que te
lleguen de manera oportuna y en
cualquiera de los casos
inténtalo y aunque fracase las
probabilidades de aprender algo de esta
experiencia son muchas no dije es ese
no dejes ir esa oportunidad que tal vez
marque tu futuro e incluso tu vida
la mía cambio y mucho gracias al poder
aventurarme y al experimentar con cosas
que tal vez nunca imaginé he tenido
nuevas experiencias
he conocido a mentes con los mismos
objetivos que yo e incluso ha ganado
ciertos concursos
pero obviamente no todo fue color de
rosa pues también tuve fallas y fracasos
mismas que me enseñaron a nunca rendirme
y seguir adelante
nunca te subestimes nunca pienses que no
puedes sólo porque alguien te lo dijo
todos estos van a ser unos comentarios
que te van a impulsar a decir mira cómo
lo hago
no digas que no tienen ningún talento
solo porque alguien te lo dijo sigue
explorando nuevas maneras de disfrutar
tu tiempo porque puede que ahí
encuentres tu verdadera pasión
empodera t porque gracias a eso nos
vamos a sentir capaces de cosas que si
son posibles recuerda que las barreras
son para derribarlas y las metas para
lograrlas
somos capaces de hasta lo inimaginable
entonces que hace falta valor y aventura
me gustaría dejarlos con una frase de
una de las mentes más brillantes de la
ciencia albert einstein quien dijo la
persona que sigue a la multitud no va a
llegar más allá de la multitud la
persona que camine sola probablemente
llega a lugares donde nunca nadie está